The very first thing before we get into
the conversation... I've put together a
little something with some of the
photos that I liked the most from
the large set that Fred shared with us.
And I want to say a few things over it.
So this is 85 photos in 365 seconds
that I've put together for you.
It's going to let us just dive straight into the work
and I'm gonna just say a couple things over it to
hopefully introduce some of the
themes we're gonna go into tonight.
Is that good, Fred?
Do you want to say anything before I launch into that?
Fred: Yes. Lock the doors don't let anybody out!
This is your life, Fred Lyon.
So here we go...
Fred Lyon and San Francisco.
Our two subjects of the night.
So we'll start with these 85 photos in 365 seconds...
And we talked about how...
photography is really all about time.
So I'm going to say a few words
and stir up the themes.
These postcards from the past...
Some icons from today's San Francisco
you'll recognize...
other things that hint at an age gone by.
There's nature and culture and art
and commerce intermingled.
...in a San Francisco we all know well.
It was a night like this long ago.
Let's have a look.
Maybe even gawk.
The frame shows us scenes that are old,
but maybe new to us.
While others are familiar.
Persistent and enduring.
The present decontextualized by seeing
it also existed in the past.
Sometimes a dramatic new vantage point.
Or the same again. Enduring.
Change that stays the same.
But different.
Cities are like this.
Stable but dynamic.
Still but in motion.
Like what we call "pace layers" here at Long Now.
Culture and nature up against each other.
An entangling of governance and
infrastructure.
And commerce.
All those parts moving in concert.
And contrast.
Some things fleeting never to return.
Others continuous. The persistent set.
Though costumes may change...
with fashion.
Steps on the temporal path
to where we are now.
Even though we're in the same place all along.
But there are odd artifacts in the midst.
Some are surreal.
Or real, but still strange.
Others seem banal...
which makes their details irrefutable.
The photos remind us there's a story to the moment
and to each face.
And more stories.
Every car connects lives...
transit... an open window...
Travel between places... between stories.
Stories frozen in a moment or a trajectory.
How did the moment end?
What happened next?
Where are they now?
Around the block or the world?
Maybe the surreal meeting the ordinary
is actually always present.
The iconic object under maintenance.
Golden Gate Park's glory, framed as a sliver.
Beside the fact of all our humanity.
A front yard, rare in San Francisco,
with an unnatural glow.
Strange things, maybe from before
you came to town.
Did you hear about that accordion house?
Who's this guy?
There's a story behind each picture-making, too.
Practice. Choices. Luck. And timing.
In a sense we're all in the currents of time.
Rushing past in youth.
Changing pace as life goes on.
Our memory is biased to big occasions.
So we may miss how sweet
an everyday moment actually is.
Just another day at work.
The same old commute.
Home sweet home.
Each moment every day open to routine
or epic adventure.
A photo's not worth a thousand words.
It's different.
Sublime. The photo brings feelings in between words.
So I'll stop the words,
and just give you Fred's photos
for a little longer...
85 photos in 365 seconds. We made it!
Fred: Play them again.
Michael: Thanks everybody, have a great night!
And we end with 4 iconic San Francisco shots.
These are Fred's "skinnies."
Do you want to say a quick word about skinnies?
Then we'll go back into...
Fred: Actually it was an art director
who was working on a new magazine a long time ago
and he had columns, vertical columns he had to fill.
And he said, do you have any skinny pictures?
I said, why? He said, well I have a client
who has some very bad copy. And I thought
if we put a large picture instead of the bad copy...
And so, you know, these are just croppings.
And I thought, hey, this is fun.
And I kind of like the look of them.
And it's a sort of an elegant proportion.
It was a great success.
So I've been making them ever since.
It's just a cropping, but
San Francisco is a very vertical town,
and so why not do vertical pictures?
It also encouraged me to make a lot of vertical pictures
because I discovered early on,
when I was really starving and...
I was being paid by page rate.
And I discovered that if I shot horizontals
the best I could hope for was a half-page.
But if I shot vertical I might get a full page.
And so I really learned to shoot a lot of verticals.